[Musique]
m
peu
[Musique]
bonjour amis appellent rifosta janaza
blanco dit kaffrine donc ma les
bénévoles m'a toujours été bénévole est
actuellement les ans l'association les
orchidées à la ravine-des-cabris des
plus trentaine d'années
cette association là c'est l'association
personnages et intergénérationnelles le
plus jeune lena 91 ans est le plus jeune
est à cinq ans parce que m'a trouvé y
avait quand même une injustice quelque
part par rapport à nos aînés donc nous
occupe tout ce qui est culturel et
autres hôtes à savoir accompagnement
l'entrée de la solidarité au niveau des
personnes âgées et la défense de la
culture réunionnaise
il y avait eu honte parce que kaka la
peau quand on criera sacem est là et
banale connus samedi
donc il y accompagne les gens surtout
les personnes âgées dans toutes leurs
démarches administratives maladie parce
que n'occupant mois des personnes peu
d'avancé à parkinson alzheimer musicale
toute la panoplie quoi et même mis dans
les hauteurs les denrées donc ça va
chercher et me d'amazon et senna soucis
ce que nous savons des tirs
le mot le plus fort le respect sans
respect nous ça va nulle part
c'est comme un arbre sans racine sympa
lui donc il veut tout d'y apprendre
comment depuis maintenant et puis savoir
les très bien mumbai oublie pas d'outil
sorte la tradition comme on veut avancer
dans la vie ce qui n'est pas au sort que
ce que me veil qui change c'est que à
l'école diazote la réunion c ou quoi
comme en france est le fier d'être
ancien mais qu'il est venu à la réunion
quan ninh a comme une tradition si mal
et marron pourquoi manu marocain bukavu